I can't sorry
even I'm annoyed with myself hi guys my
name is good no babe you don't know now
you know you're just different now it is
the end of March here are some things
that I enjoyed this month I'm like every
monthly favorites video here's the
caveat I may have included some and/or
all these things in a previous favorites
video but that does not change the fact
that I enjoy it very much
ya can see I am see this is a candle
that I got from Target it's a brand
white barn which I have no idea about
white barn is probably going to
eventually be my stripper name in the
Sunbird ma mint I don't know what
bergamot is but this smells so good and
this burned so slowly it was like a
really bad UTI it burns really slowly
which is great for a candle and it
smells like bergamot mint I guess I
don't know what's bergamot
let's learn together now this is
entertainment hey orange it's an orange
oh it's a fragrance citrus
oh yeah I thought it was a wood classic
first world problem confusion yeah this
does smell citrusy and minty and I like
that the outside looks like this like
marble thing is very trendy and everyone
likes makes me feel really Pinterest
cute Mac yeah can't see ya happy yeah
this is a plant thing home decor item
it's a really cute little geometric
plant holder with an air plant in it
that's actually alive but the best part
is it's got magnets on the back so we
goes on your refrigerator or any other
sort of magnetized surface so it makes
our refrigerator - refrigerator is kind
of August spot no offense refrigerators
thank you for your service the insides
don't mess the outside but now they kind
of do this looks moist right now because
I watered it right before this video so
they realize kind of dying which is
impossible to do with an air plant don't
want anyone tell you you can't do think
I'm killing an airplane this was like
three or four dollars I got it at low
noon - I like next let's see if the FAA
IOC man this favorites video really
shows my age who so far favorited an air
plant a can
and now some glass cleaning wipes I'm
fun
these are Windex wipe if any of you give
a [ __ ] about cleaning windows or mirrors
or any sort of glass like surface these
are pushing off them I'm a white person
okay I'm a lazy piece of cleaning for me
if it's very easy I will do it and this
makes cleaning glass and windows super
easy I use Clorox wipes on every surface
of my house but I can't use them on
window and now I can use the cute neck
yeah can't say yeah yeah yeah so you can
live it is a makeup product I don't if
there's something to do with my eyes is
it just that they're extraordinary tired
guys I played hard this weekend and I
did not work hard and I'm a little sad
about it so bear with me
oh my god I'm fun if you're we don't
know if I've had this in a favorite
video in the past that I have been
meaning to put it in a favorites video
it's called lip cheek and basically it
is clear liquid that you paint onto your
lips on top of your lipstick and it
keeps your lipstick from smudging off it
basically turns any lipstick into a lip
stain and I love it I never wear
lipstick because I'm a awful woman
I'm a nasty woman I expose my lipstick
constantly so I only wear lip stains but
I have a bunch of lipstick colors that I
really like and so I found this on
Amazon I think because candy Johnson had
mentioned it or a product similar to
this and I've been loving it it works
really well I have a lipstick on right
now with this on top of it it does sting
a little bit but I love sting is a very
sexy musician and it's slightly drying
but it's not as drying as a lot of other
lip stain so I think it's great yeah
yeah TLC yeah see if you watch my
recreating Genesis Coachella look you
know what this is this is a foundation
wrong colors pump up rush foundation and
I use it in that video for my foundation
and I just really like this a lot one
because you don't have to dirty a Beauty
Blender or sponge or anything it's all
right in here you basically push this
button and then the foundation comes out
the top and you just shoot this all over
your face you just
really paint the white barn it's not
very translucent but it also doesn't
feel like you're wearing a [ __ ] ton of
makeup the technical term for kicking
your face wearing a [ __ ] kind of makeup
and that's it I like it you neck look
Cassie I up the action yeah this is a
skirt that I bought from Zara but it's
got shirts underneath your real price so
hard you should feel so embarrassed
right now you go pray so hard oh I got
you so good comments a sneaky skirt
because it's not a skort escort you can
see like the shorts in the back which I
don't necessarily love this just has
sneaky shorts built-in underneath which
is fantastic and makes me so much more
comfortable wearing this also I realized
that I love this color yellow they think
and we'll be wearing much of it this
spring and summer and there's pretty
inexpensive so those are right now yeah
yeah can you see yeah see this is my
laptop but I'm not favoriting the laptop
I'm favoring this laptop case that I got
from Amazon
I've always do not have people with
laptop cases and I always thought really
is that necessary and then I realized
how dirty my hands are and how gross my
laptop looks when I pull it out on
planes and how embarrassed I feel by the
association of me being just a nasty
woman so I got a case which I think like
ten dollars or something relatively
cheap use really nice because it's like
matte plastic finish so that feels good
and you can tell because it's still
dirty fingerprints all over why am i
handsome I haven't really dirty because
I always touch my face and my foundation
and then when I touch things you know at
least it by like murder someone I will
never ever get away with it so that's a
cute human trait but I really like it
because it makes my computer look like
cute if people see this or like that
girl has her [ __ ] together and then I
open my laptop how dirty it is and
they're like oh wow I got pranked so
hard she definitely does not next me
happy I'm singing I'm trying to say yeah
this is a tiny backpack also from Zara
I love backpack I can carry backpack all
the time now I like having two
hands-free because I'm a clumsy person
and so there's a possibility I could
fall at any moment and it's better for
me to have two hands to brace myself
also they're just convenient it was
pretty inexpensive and the best part is
all of the straps are totally adjustable
so you can take them off completely and
carry it like a purse or you can adjust
them so it's like a crossbody or
whatever and it's cute it's got a little
pocket in the front and then cut all
that it's very 90 but upgraded yes if
you can't see it but you can see it's a
court you can but you can definitely
hear it how did your call amazing
youtuber extraordinaire has an album
cross-strait all my life if you haven't
heard it already it's so good and I've
recently been so obsessed with the
entire album you just have like a couple
music videos walnuts RuPaul and Wilma
Bob the drag queen I love both of those
human beings and they're such great
music videos and the songs are so great
whole concept album is incredible it's
basically about the Wizard of Oz but
mapped over like his life and like
current society and all these like very
interesting relevant themes but still
completely inspired by the story of The
Wizard of Oz I highly recommend you guys
go check it out plus hazard full of the
most inspiring youtubers he works as a
saw he's so talented I couldn't be more
of a fan and you watch some of the music
videos from Stella's
you might see a certain try hug let me
know if you find me
Thank You taja for giving me new music
that I can binge so hard on for the
famous video let me know what you guys
have been loving this month and feel
free to subscribe to the channel make
videos Monday Wednesday Friday sometime
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up so I know and I'll see you another
time in the future I don't know keeping
Waldo word that hat where'd that hat
where'd that hat oh he'll dig who you
have had a weekend I was going to say do
you think
Waldo wore that hat so frequently
because he never washes hair Where's
Waldo not in the shower